on est très attendu sur ces Jeux
Olympiques les gars j'attends de vous un
comportement irréprochable les
gars le mec il a porté plain on fait
quoi maintenant moi j'ai rien fait
moi c'est pas moi qui a fait c'est mon
pote qui a fait c'est lui qui avait le
fusil la gosse je vous jure je l'ai pas
touché de quoi vous me parlez la gosse
la gosse mais moi moi c'est bagarre moi
c'est bagarre les tiges c'est pas les
vacances les il va être avec nous
pendant quelques mois là au jardin il a
joué au con et il a perdu voilà bah nous
on rien on est là gros si vous vous
approchez de la boxe de près de loin
c'est la prison s-toi garde ta jambe
gauche devant tu auras plus de
stabilité ton boulot c'est que tu vas
dans les écuries tu nettoies tout le
crotin partout tu fais ça bien
nickel sérieux tuas pas peur des chevaux
toi non bon bah ça va bien se passer
alors bah oui ça va bien se passer ça va
bien se
passer tu rentres tu cours bouclier et
tu tombes je rentre je cours bouclier je
tombe mais tu es en fond toi
voilà ce que je te propose moi je
t'entraîne à la boxe tu deviens une
grande championne je veux 10000 € je
pensais plus à 15 € moi
okissa c'est une jeune fille qui est
fragile c'est notre boulot de savoir ce
qui est bon pour les enfants calz cal
cal c'est la prière fois quelqu se de
comme ça ah ok en fait tu te s la petite
quoiuis le début tu me parles des
combats qui vont changer ma vie arrêtei
làain je la re
seule tuas un vrai talent te faire
croire que tu peux pas devenir qui tu
veux dans la
vie tu éta es où ça c'est quoi
c'est pour faire peur au sanglier bah
non c'est au cas où il y a des
pédophiles tu vois je le frappe les
couilles après je leur enfonce dans le
cul
d'accord